we are taking you behind the scenes of
the new irresistible adorable baby
calendar from an get even
she has never led cameras inside one of
her photo shoots before but this
calendar is different you could even say
it's written in the stars this is little
too young she's sixteen days old we're
just trying to get her off to sleep this
is this is one of the most important
steps in the whole process yeah sweet
slumbering babies and whimsical poses it
just kinda makes you want to go ah by
getting a newborn to cooperate can be
tricky business generally if they warm
and I've got a full tummy and we've got
a very warm studio here they'll sleep
but you know I could prove myself to be
a liar in a few minutes time the theme
of the shoot today is one of the signs
of the zodiac
today is Virgo and I'm a Virgo too so
this has got to go well for sure when I
come to the studio the first thing we do
is we get them undressed and just in a
diaper and we wrap them in a soft cloth
and then get the moms to feed them and
they go off to sleep everything needs to
revolve around the babies once they come
on set and so you know we spent all of
yesterday setting this up and lighting
it and making sure everything's
absolutely perfect and props are always
baby friendly the Dove is warm and soft
and of course little Liana has never
left unattended in fact Anne's assistant
will be spotting her the whole time so
I'll take a little Photoshop magic to
get the final shot we photograph ahead
with a little hat and then I'll move
around
and hopefully the little links abacavir
and so front like the legs okay no
critical together later 31 babies and
all will have modeled for the 2017
calendar it took three little ones just
to get today's job done got her in the
end we always do the world is turn into
such a horrible place and there's so
much fear and and there's so much
bitterness and there's so much anger and
you look a little newborn baby and you
just think that the absolute purity and
and the potential that's sitting right
there for goodness you know okay look at
this pictures all day long they're
fantastic I know well the 2017 calendar
will mark Anne's twenty-fifth in a row
and the good news here she has actually
find a deal to keep him coming through
2019